in indonesia's south kalimantan province
on the island of borneo
heavy rain has lashed these villages and
towns for days
tens of thousands of people have been
evacuated
some are choosing to stay put fawzi
rahman has been sleeping outside his
house for nearly a week
it's the first time he's experienced a
flood
i have to stay here to look after my
belongings people might steal them at
night
also i have to watch in case the
electricity short circuits
flooding is common in indonesia during
the monsoon season
but this year 11 of the 13 districts in
south kalimantan have been inundated
some for the first time ever bantuaname
i need help the basics like food we
cannot work right now and my husband
hasn't been able to work because of
covet 19.
evacuation centers are operating around
affected areas
but volunteers say their resources are
stretched
we need blankets for the elderly we only
have three we need food for them
and for the toddlers we're also lacking
medicine
some of those here are suffering from
diarrhea and skin infections caused by
contaminated water
and many say they don't know what
they'll do when they return to their
houses
all my possessions are gone the water in
my house is chest height
president joko widodo visited the area
earlier in the week
this is a major flood that may not have
occurred in south carolina for more than
50 years due to heavy rainfall
but environmental groups say land
degradation and
deforestation is making the floods worse
these floods are particularly bad
because from the total 3.7 million
hectares of land in south carolina
50 is already burdened by mining and
palm oil plantations
for him and others this crisis isn't
just about
rain but the mismanagement of land
jessica washington
al jazeera jakarta